من الصعب اختيار أكاذيب
رئاسة دونالد ترامب
لأن هناك الكثير من الأكاذيب
لكنني فكرت مليًا في الأمر
وحصرت القائمة إلى أربعة
أعتقد أنها تخبرنا
حقًا قصة وأعتقد أنه من الواضح ماذا
أخطر كذبة
لرئاسة ترامب كانت حقًا أنها
عائلة من الأكاذيب ، لقد كانت أكاذيبه
حول الطمع 19. هناك كذبة
أن الفيروس الذي هو أكثر فتكًا من
الأنفلونزا يعادل الأنفلونزا
هذه إنفلونزا مثل هذا.  إنفلونزا كذبة
مفادها أن وضع الوباء
الذي كان دائمًا خارج نطاق السيطرة كان
تحت السيطرة تمامًا ،
فنحن نسيطر عليه تمامًا
وكانت هناك كذبة أنه كرر
عشرات المرات
أن الفيروس الذي كان ينتشر
على نطاق واسع كان
يختفي  كل هذه الادعاءات
أوضحت للأمريكيين
أنه لا يتعين عليهم تغيير الكثير
بشأن سلوكهم وأن الكثير منهم
لم يفعل الآن لا يمكننا تحديد كيف كانت الأمور ستختلف
لو كان الرئيس أكثر صدقًا.
لقد وصلنا إلى أكثر من 390 ألف
حالة وفاة أمريكية ، ومن
المعقول أن نخاطر
بأن بعضًا منها على الأقل كان من
الممكن تجنبه إذا قال ترامب الحقيقة ،
أين مدققو الحقائق الذين تعرفهم
بعضًا من أكثر
الأشخاص المخادعين في وسائل الإعلام
هم مدققو الحقائق المزعومون
، لقد كان الأمر محبطًا للغاية بشكل عام
للتحقق من كل كلمة من دونالد
ترامب
لمدة أربع سنوات ، وأعتقد أن الكذبة الوحيدة الأكثر
إحباطًا
هي كذبه بأنه الفائز
الفعلي في انتخابات 2020 ،
لقد شاركت في انتخابين  لقد فزت
بهما ، والثاني فزت بهما
أكبر بكثير من الأول حسنًا ،
إنه أمر محبط الآن بسبب مدى
فظاعة أنه انعكاس مباشر
للواقع القابل للتحقق ، لكنه أكثر
إحباطًا بسبب عدد الملايين
من مؤيدي ترامب
يعتقدون أنه  الحقيقة ومدى فتكنا وزعزعتنا
للاستقرار ،
أصبحنا واضحين الآن أن الاعتقاد الخاطئ يمكن أن يكون ،
أعتقد أن ملحمة هذه الكذبة
بالذات علمتنا أن مشكلة الحقيقة للأمة
تتجاوز  مشكلة ترامب ، إنها مشكلة طويلة الأمد
للولايات المتحدة أن
ملايين المواطنين
قد سقطوا في أعماق حفرة أرنب مؤامرة ،
ولا أعرف كيف أصلح هذا عندما
أفكر في مدى التزام هذا
الرئيس بالكذب ، كما
أفكر في شاربي  بوابة قد
تتذكر ما حدث
في تغريدة ترامب في عام 2019 أن ألاباما كانت
في خطر أكبر من إعصار دوريان
مما كان متوقعًا في الأصل
من مكتب الأرصاد الجوية الفيدرالي في ألاباما ثم
غرد
أنه لن يتأثر أي ألاباما فعليًا وبعد
ذلك بدلاً من مجرد إجراء
تصحيح سريع وسهل  شرع الرئيس
في حملة محمومة
استمرت لعدة أيام لإثبات أن
خطأه
كان في الواقع على حق طوال هذه
الحملة ، وبلغت ذروتها مع الصورة الرمزية الآن
للرئيس وهو يعرض خريطة الأعاصير
التي تم تغييرها بشكل فظي ومن الواضح
باستخدام علامة حادة كان هذا
لطيفًا.  من المضحك ولكنه كان أيضًا
مزعجًا ومخبرًا ومهمًا
أنه لم يوضح لنا فقط المدى الذي
كان عليه الرئيس  على استعداد للذهاب لإقناع
الأمريكيين بالكذبة
، علمنا أيضًا أنه لم يكن
كاذبًا وحيدًا هناك بمفرده ،
علمنا لاحقًا أن كبار مسؤولي البيت الأبيض
قد قفزوا إلى العمل
وراء الكواليس لمحاولة ثني
سلطات الطقس الفيدرالية
إلى  بعبارة أخرى ،
كانت نزوات الرئيس مدعومة بجهاز قوي كامل
على استعداد للقتال لجعل
أكاذيبه تبدو صحيحة ،
وهذا أمر مخيف الآن ، دعونا نتحدث عن
كذبي الشخصي
المفضل في هذه الرئاسة ، إنها كذبة
قالها ترامب
أكثر من 20 مرة على الرغم من أنها تجعل
لا معنى له على الإطلاق
وفي الواقع كنت في ميشيغان ، ولا
أعرف ما إذا كان أي شخص يتذكر هذا
قبل 12 عامًا ، فقد أعطوني رجل العام الذي
تتذكره
لم يعش دونالد ترامب أبدًا في ميشيغان ،
لماذا من المحتمل أن يكون اسمه
رجل ميشيغان  قبل عام من رئاسته
، لم يكن ليكون كذلك ، لقد
نظر الآخرون في هذا
الأمر ، لم يحدث أبدًا ، أنا مفتون جدًا
بهذه الكذبة
بسبب كيفية توضيحها تمامًا
طبيعة خيانة نزاهة الرئيس دونالد ترامب
يكذب السياسيون الآخرون أحيانًا في
تضليل مبالغ
فيه للتغلب على فضيحة أو بيع
سياسة مفضلة
أو الفوز بأوراق رابحة في الانتخابات ، كذبت بشأن
كل شيء ،
كانت أصغر الأشياء التي لم تكن كذبة تافهة
للغاية أو سخيفة للغاية بحيث لا يمكن اختلاقها
أو  للتكرار ولن يمنعه أي قدر من
فحص الدهون